linear algebra courses often include a
part about changing the basis of a
vector or a matrix and in my experience
this part of the course can be a bit
confusing especially this mysterious
change of basis formula they give you
what you'll see in this video is if you
really understand what a change of basis
actually is how to do it will become
obvious to you and you won't really need
the formula after all so here's what a
change of basis is imagine Alice is
trying to describe her vector to Bob
the way to describe any vector is to
pick a basis and then the vector can be
described as a linear combination of
those basis vectors she can write this
compactly by writing it as a column like
this and she can tell Bob what that
column is but here's a problem Bob isn't
using the same basis vectors as her he's
using this basis instead and so to him
this column vector means this sum which
is this vector which is completely
different from the one that Alice had in
mind
Alice realizes that for Bob to
understand what vector she meant she
needs to describe her vector in his
basis for him that's what a change of
basis is taking a vector written in one
basis and writing it in another basis
let's see how to do this in a simple
example first pretend that a Bob's basis
is this one analysis basis is exactly
the same but rotated by 45 degrees say
the vector that Alice wants to
communicate to Bob is her second basis
vector this one here she knows exactly
what Bob's basis vectors are and she
wants to write her vector in his basis
as in she wants to write that a to
equals something times B 1 plus
something times B 2
what should these numbers be here are
four different options choose which it
is and put your answer in the poll in
the corner don't worry you don't need to
do any calculation to figure it out you
should be able to work it out from where
the minus signs are pause the video now
to think about it the answer is to b1
minus b2 divided by square root 2 this
is because if you turn b2 around to get
minus b2 then add these two vectors you
do get something in the same direction
as a tube but it needs to be shortened
if you aren't sure how to approach that
question may I suggest my video on
vectors as a refresher the link is in
the description and in the corner now
say that Alice wanted to write her first
basis vector in Bob's basis which one of
these options would that be
hopefully you can see that it's one okay
so Alice now knows how to write these
two basis vectors in bulbs language but
what if she wants to send some other
vector well now she basically can Y
imagine she writes her vector as this
column of numbers that means the vector
is this linear combination of her basis
vectors she needs to translate this
whole thing to Bob's basis but she
already knows how to translate her own
basis vectors and after doing that she's
done right because the resulting column
is in Bob's basis now what we've learned
from this example is no matter what kind
of vector Alice has and what basis she's
written it in as long as Alice somehow
figures out how to write each one of her
basis vectors in Bob's basis that's
enough to translate her vector to his
basis we could leave this here and be
happy but there's a really convenient
way for Alice to do all this translating
we could represent it as a matrix as in
Alice just puts in her vector in her
basis and the matrix spits out what it
should be in Bob's we're going to call
this the change of basis matrix going
back to our example Alice knows that her
first basis vector is written like this
in Bob's basis from this fact alone and
not from any calculations work out what
the first column of the change of basis
matrix should be pause the video and
give yourself a minute to think about it
[Music]
if you want sure how to do this I
explained it in my video about matrices
so go have a look at that in the
description and my playlist linked in
the corner but remember the columns of a
matrix just tell you what happens
through the basis vectors the first
column is what happens to the first
basis vector here it becomes this
similarly the second basis vector
becomes this and so that's your second
column this is exactly the matrix we
wanted because if Alice puts in the
column CD it comes out as this column
just as we calculated earlier but
there's one really strange thing about
this matrix usually a matrix takes a
vector and transforms it to some other
vector that's not what's happening here
the matrix takes a vector and gives you
back the exact same vector it just
changes how you describe it that's
something to keep in mind but despite
this the change of basis matrix is very
useful for example you can compute its
inverse which has an important property
the inverse takes a vector that's in
Bob's basis and translates it back to
Alice's basis that's just because that's
what inverses do they undo the original
matrix
so once Alice has figured out what the
change of basis matrix Q is if she wants
to translate a vector Bob tells her to
something she understands she just
applies q inverse to it there's another
reason that these two matrices are super
useful if Alice now wants to describe a
whole linear transformation to Bob not
just a vector you can use Q and Q
inverse to do it let's see how this
works for the case when the linear
transformation is from n dimensions to n
dimensions the easiest way to describe a
linear transformation is to write it as
a matrix but the problem is the way the
matrix looks depends on what basis
you've used this is what hers looks like
in her basis now she needs to translate
it to Bob's basis which means it will
look very different from her own here's
how she wants this matrix to take a
vector written in Bob's basis and do the
linear transformation but her current
matrix only takes vectors written in her
basis so why don't we just translate
Bob's vector by applying Q inverse this
writes Bob's vector in her basis and in
this new form you can apply her matrix
to it okay great so are we done
pause the video to think about whether
this matrix M a q inverse is the linear
transformation we want in Bob's basis
then choose one of these options in the
poll one is yes two is no but I don't
know what to do next three is she should
apply M inverse again and four is she
should apply M pause the video now and
try and work it out
[Music]
the answer is she's not quite done
because the column vector you end up
with is an Alice's basis now but that's
no good because Bob is expecting that
his new matrix takes a vector written in
his way to another vector also written
in his basis unlike this which is in
Alice's basis we have the right vector
it's just written in the wrong way so we
should apply Q to it and get it to Bob
spaces and now it's perfect
overall what happened is it got
translated to Alice's basis then you
apply Alice's matrix then you translate
it back to Bob's basis in other words
Bob's matrix is Q ma Q inverse it's a
really simple concept when you
understand it but it's super important
for example when you have some X Y
coordinates and someone else is using
different coordinates to you you'll also
see it crop up lots in my quantum
mechanics videos and I'll explain the
link more once I've covered direct
notation but before you go I'd really
recommend you try these two simple
multiple-choice questions to test
whether you really understood this video
and to help it stick question 1 suppose
that Bob's basis is this and Alice's
basis is exactly the same except she
switches which one she calls her first
basis vector and which one she calls her
second what is the change of basis
matrix pick from these options and put
your answer in the poll
question two I did the simple case where
Alice's matrix is square what happens in
the general case where her matrix is
from vector space one two vector space -
she has this basis for the first vector
space and this one for her second one
Bob has these bases and say Q and W are
the change of basis vectors between
these spaces what is the formula for
Bob's version of this matrix here are
your options and again put it in the
poll as always there are hints in the
description
your final homework which I'd really
appreciate if you did is if you could
tell me what you think of this series so
far and what you think I can improve
because I'd really like to get better at
this anyway the next video will be about
inner products aka scalar products or
dot products after that we can start
slowly linking all this linear algebra
back to quantum mechanics by talking
about fun stuff like direct notation and
unitary time evolution I'll try to have
the next one up in two weeks so
subscribe if you'd like to see it thanks
a lot for watching
[Music]